welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home's
oscar-nominated visual effects are now
getting a closer look thanks to
behind-the-scenes interviews by the
artists who worked on this film proving
how tom holland is really the little
punk in the trampoline park dodgeball
court who's impossible to hit ah stand
still little twerp and now being
revealed are all kinds of amazing little
details that otherwise we never would
have seen in this film that just make it
love it even more so i'm gonna break
them all down my favorite new detail
comes up in the film's final battle in
the shot where andrew and toby mask up
and split up now previous footage shows
the shot when the camera glides away
from the actors on the scaffolding
except notice they are pantomiming
pulling their masks over their faces no
actual masks in their hands in the final
shot their masks were composited
digitally i still love it though because
the smoothness and the timing of their
gesture was just so perfect for two
spideys who have had to quickly mask up
dozens or hundreds of times in their
lives and the costume designer
sanjamokovich hayes explained why this
could not be done practically a mask the
intricate part of the costume and they
have skull caps that are molded to their
heads so they are not wearing it just
over their bare head those are intricate
to make it as tight as possible not to
add to any of the volume of the skull
necessarily but keep the shape and the
profile and then we have a special
costume when they are supposed to be
without the mask then it's as we call it
a turtleneck costume and then they're in
a costume without the hood all those
hoods have a frame for the eyes to
literally snap into them and there are
different kinds of eyes and folks i've
tried it it's not easy to do this
quickly
i am amazing but uh let's rewind the
moment peter leaves the sanctum and the
doors shut in his face are you telling
me
that you didn't even think to plead your
case with him first before you asked me
to brainwash the entire world
i mean when you put it like that then
the movie's vfx supervisor kelly port
revealed that on this day on the set
they only had the doorway of the sanctum
and they had to composite the walls and
the windows behind it down the street he
also pointed to the extras in the cars
that you can see behind peter further
down the street some of these
pedestrians are digital pedestrians and
some of them are extras that were shot
on blue screen it's a combination of
both and when you look at this scene in
high definition you can see how the two
women closer to tom look more lifelike
like extra shot on a blue screen and
indeed they do look a bit composited in
the background there but the other man
walking away from us further behind
super out of focus is a cgi character
but again the fact that we don't even
notice this while we watch the movie is
the point they just needed crowds and
motion in the background to make the
city feel like a city and it totally
works port also revealed that on the
other this call flash thompson at that
mit mixer was also a composited shot
because tony riverlori wasn't available
so they had to shoot him on a blue
screen plate so the fact that both sides
of this phone call had to be
reconstructed in some way with vfx when
they definitely previously had a full
sanctum edifice for other shots of the
movie plus tony rivera's scheduling
issues with the mit mixer setup tell us
that this whole phone call was probably
part of reshoots after their main sets
were dismantled and actors moved on to
other projects which makes sense if you
think about it peter getting from the
sanctum to find the abc on the bridge
was all just a bit of rushed a to b
exposition in that first act and you can
actually see where they inserted new adr
audio for flash earlier on to set this
up you guys didn't get in yeah because
we're actually friends with spider-man
uh yeah
i better get going there's a mixer for
new admissions and
sorry guys
so that brings us to the bridge battle
which is most impressive to break down
to learn how much of the stunts tom
holland did himself when he first lands
on that poll kelly port confirmed that
tom himself did that landing for
reference wearing his wrinkled suit
which peter as a character was wearing
underneath the armor the whole scene and
making it super wrinkled was apparently
tom's idea tom also did the drop from
the overhang into the roll on the ground
and then later this is insane tom did
the whole run from doc ock's claws
springing off the hood of a car running
over to another car kicking off from
another car onto a tripoli trampoline
he said what now and then flips and then
rolls and then runs over the abc's car
and by the way later in the movie when
peter tries to escape strange with the
box but then flips through a portal and
lands on a moving car and then flips off
of that that was another stunt that tom
did himself practicing it over and over
again with the wire team
really all of these stunts gave the
film's vfx crew and the other actors a
reference point so that spider-man in
this movie whenever we see him would
match tom holland's specific movement
his timing his acting his franticness
that he plays everything with it's just
one of the things that has made his
version of spider-man feel so authentic
whenever we see him and so fun to watch
we know this is always the same kid yeah
i know i can seem kind of wound up as
i'm going through these theories and
easter eggs so to relax i like having a
nice glass of wine after a hard day i
especially like having a glass that
someone else has done the work of
picking it out just for me well bright
cellars matches your preferences to the
perfect wines from around the world you
take their simple seven question quiz
and then they ship you a customized box
of wine right to your door each box
comes with these cool wine educator
cards that teach you all about the wine
here's the box i got this month what do
we got in it this month's box includes
the cabin five according to the card
this zinfandel is like a rich strawberry
jam with ripe fruit flavors contrasting
beautifully with the notes of freshly
cracked black pepper velvety texture
with silky tannins i think i'm just
gonna walk around the apartment with
this bottle like a pirate pirate with
great taste i've received a bunch of
boxes from bright cellars over the past
year and based on my feedback they've
adjusted the wines that they send me
every time i get something new i always
enjoy them their selection includes
wines beyond your typical grocery store
wine with sustainable varieties and
biodynamic wines bright cellars is
giving our viewers 50 off their first
six bottle box that's six bottles for
just 45
crazy good value support the channel by
following the link to take the quiz and
get started today kelly port also
pointed out how they had to change the
green route sign to add jfk airport even
though this isn't on the sign on the
brooklyn queens expressway to indicate
that that's where the abc was headed
toward he also confirmed some of the
easter eggs that we spotted in the scene
the nod to stan lee's birthday on the
taxicab the delayed daily bugle live
feed on the girls tablet and the
changing of the lights of doc ock's
claws from red to blue to white
throughout the film to signal his
control over them but also as he wipes
from the practical shots to the vfx
notice how the license plate numbers on
the cars always change now they shot
this movie in atlanta so all these new
york plates were custom made anyway but
they always swap out the numbers so that
they can hide in their easter egg codes
confirming the ones that i spotted the
anagram for spideys and the nods of the
debut comic issues of doc ock and lizard
all these were not coincidental my
friends but then kelly port pointed out
this shot are you okay now
which is just a great example of
multiple components working together
paul and newsome's terrified performance
because she did not like being suspended
like this and then in the reflection of
the car's window they added in doc ock
creeping up behind peter and then when
doc ock tries to stab peter in the chest
they had tom wear a patch of his
wrinkled suit costume over his fractal
suit in order to best capture the motion
of the dangling necktie now it was
actually revealed that one original
conception for the scene that they
actually prevised out would have shown
peter fighting goblin here whipping the
glider out from under him causing goblin
to crash through a sign and then the
glider to hit doc ock now kelly port
oversaw all the different vfx teams that
worked on different parts of the movie
one of those companies was digital
domain they did a lot of the effects on
the multiverse men in happy's condo
specifically the shot when sandman sits
on the couch and tries to wipe the sand
away
oh sorry
if you look closely on flint's second
wipe he actually spills more sand on the
cushion from his own hand and their
footage also shows how the golden
integrated suit created when dock
returns pito's nanotech to him was all
added to vfx tom was actually wearing
its normal far from home arrow red and
black suit throughout the movie's final
act and for every single shot they had
to vfx the gold parts of it over him but
in this shot where he purchased on
goblin's shoulders punching him in
addition to the golden parts of the suit
they also added a bit of
thickness to tom's arm and his shoulders
i mean the guy's already in great shape
but i think they wanted him to look even
more aggro as he wailed on goblin and a
fun detail here that i just found when
electro summons the arc reactor from the
other room he's only able to do that so
quickly before peter's able to react
because the fabricator had previously
knocked a hole through the kitchen wall
i just like when gags early in a movie
are repurposed later in the movie for
actual key plot implications now one
last detail hinted by kelly port about
goblin's glider glider was slightly
adjusted to be um as similar as possible
from a profile perspective but we did
take some liberties and just design
choices to kind of improve it a little
incrementally a little bit and you can
actually see those design changes in the
final fight when peter lifts the glider
trying to kill goblin with it compared
to the 2002 film they made this whole
glider a bit smaller and thinner
something easier for tom to lift and
weaponize in this critical moment but
they also made the frontal blades a bit
more retracted than they would normally
be normally they stick out like a foot
and a half from the front of the glider
here they just stick out a few inches so
that toby could catch this glider and
have this really close intimate
face-to-face moment with tom without
those blades stabbing him right in the
face now again huge congratulations to
the entire crew of this film the vfx
artists and animators the customers the
props the stunt coordinators the special
effects crew everyone because the more
we learn about all of your hard work all
the artistry that went in behind the
scenes of this movie the more reasons we
find do love this film you can follow me
on instagram and twitter at e-a-vos
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you